the epic tale of bikes bring me I'm rush
so premium rush is the story of a bunch
of bike couriers the main one is Joseph
gordon-levitt he's like the best of the
best in that field and I really like
that when movies do that you know no
matter what it is it could be like oh
this is the greatest Pig on earth at
getting truffles and if they sell me on
it I'll be like cool that pig is the
best Pig on earth at getting truffles
let's watch the movie because I like
seeing a master of a craft at work you
know and on this particular day Joseph
gordon-levitt has to take a package from
point A to point B and well it's a
package that Michael Shannon wants and
the setup of this movie is awesome for
the first few minutes you're like I'm
into this because they break it down for
you so Wow you know they got the rules I
like it when the best the best is not
only the best of the best but he's the
best while abiding by the rules you know
he has a set of standards for himself
he's like the pedals never stop moving
you never coast your bike to get from
point A to point B in the fastest time
possible that's what we do cuz we're
awesome and had really cool effects who
run into a situation like a bunch of
cars are going and it shows the
different scenarios like that movie next
or something
it shows the ones that will fail and he
finds the right path and he just goes
and does it I thought it was a really
cool stylish thing I was excited for
this movie had all the elements in the
first few minutes to be a great movie
and then people started talking and then
the script spoke for itself
yeah the script is not that great I mean
you have these great actors in the movie
Joseph gordon-levitt plays the guy that
you're rooting for and he does his job
well you're rooting for him for the
entire movie you're like yeah dude be
awesome be the best courier possible
Michael Shannon plays the villain when
you first meet him you're like this guy
is going to kick ass I already knew the
guy was a great actor but that first
line he has with Joseph gordon-levitt
where he grabs his handlebars and he's
like do you have people who care about
you people who don't want you hurt
people who want to see you again they're
like Oh General Zod I get you and then
strangely his character just changes
into another character it was just a
cartoon villain he would say and do
things really like you are two different
people his voice even got higher he went
from menacing to really talking like
this you know you're like alright well
now you're a I mean he goes from
badass to really scared weasel it's just
about everything that dude does
the best he can but his best just isn't
good enough
save the movie because it's proof
positive that when you have a
script and a director who's apparently
on Heisenberg's blue meth it's gonna
show through in the movie and you have
that one hot asian chick from sucker
punch and I think she was in Sorority
Row also she was as bad as it gets the
entire movie she has to have this Asian
accent and it's the worst
Asian accent I've ever heard her having
an accent doesn't change the movie at
all so I can promise you this the
director saw the movie he was like I
could change one thing yeah he has to
pick one thing I guess of the things
that he will want to change in the movie
after he sees the final cut I can
promise you her having an Asian accent
is one of them it's one of those movies
it has enough high-octane tricks and
really cool things in the movie there
you're like alright I'll forget about
the script for a second but once
you get out of the movie and you go home
you start thinking about it you're like
I like the movie less and less to the
point where you're like I hate the movie
if you are a movie reviewer out there
wait a day after seeing this movie
before you actually review it let it all
soak in because I promise you by day 2
your rating will be different than it
was on day 1 and I recognize that there
is a demographic of people that will
enjoy this movie if you enjoy movies
like crank or Ghost Rider 2 I think
you're gonna enjoy it it's mindless bike
fun and that's all good but if you start
thinking about the movie at all don't do
that if you want to enjoy it and at that
point my only advice to you to enjoy the
movie you'd be hey don't use your brain
and I just can't do that to you you have
a brain use that brain might come in
handy one day in the end I will say
premium Rush is one of those movies you
won't remember in t-minus the car ride
home yep already forgot sorry General
Zod and jgl you both tried but alas it
was not enough but that's not your fault
and as I said in my last video I was
down in LA doing a podcast with schmoes
no and Katee Sackhoff is a two-hour
podcast we recap the summer movies we
talk about movies it's a lot of fun for
the first 40 minutes of that podcast we
have Sean Astin on there I put links to
the podcast below you guys should check
that out for sure I'm telling you to
check it out because of his Bar None
hands down the most fun I've ever had
talking about movies for two hours I
felt like I was just hanging out with
four friends having a good time we all
had a blast it shows you guys will have
fun check it out two hours just flies by
I promise you so when you check out the
podcast comment below let me know what
you thought of it there's a lot of fun
in there and watch the video of it too
i'm toda network link is below you see
the video of it the video is just fun as
hell you see us all reacting it's
it's the full experience friends and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]